[Music]
I'm Sally Lockwood and on this episode
of The Sky News Daily
on track is across France
tear gas fired by Riot police cars
better night business is looted and
buses smashed up the anger and violence
initially broke out in the Parisian
suburb of non-term after a French
teenager Niel melzook was shot and
killed by police at a traffic stop last
Tuesday
but the unrest quickly spread to Paris
Lille Marseille and many major French
cities
the country hasn't seen violence on this
scale since 2005 when two teenagers died
while allegedly being chased by police
three weeks of rioting Then followed
this time more than 3 000 people have
been arrested the home of a district
mayor was Ram raided by a burning car
his wife broke her leg trying to escape
Nile's death has reignited Decades of
simmering tensions in France when it
comes to racism poverty and police
brutality
if he'd been white do you think he'd
have been shot no I do not I'm very
saddened by what's happening in France
but I'm not at all surprised as the
rioting begins to come in France we'll
be surveying the aftermath bringing the
violence under control is one thing but
what do you do about the deeply rooted
social issues that could reignite again
at any moment
[Music]
later in the podcast I'll speak to Gene
Beeman who studied and written about
racism and state violence in France but
first let's speak to our Europe
correspondent Adam Parsons who's in
Paris and has been covering this story
since the riots kicked off France is in
many ways untouched and you could be a
tourist in in Paris and have a have a
great experience but if you go to
certain bits at certain times you you'll
end up in in a completely different
world and that is the same whether
you're in Paris or Leon or to lose or
killing Marseille or many other places
and if you have been over the past few
days in the wrong place at the wrong
time it's been a very dangerous corner
of the world I'm speaking to you at the
moment from which is the the small town
the suburb on the edge of Paris where uh
notably a burning car was driven not
quite into but very near to the ha the
the home of the mayor I think it would
have gone into his home without in a
small wall in front a horrendous crime a
clearly personal attempt to kill the
mayor which in fact ended up of course
in terrifying his wife and and his
children I mean these things just don't
happen normally in countries like France
and that's what has bewildered people
here is that the violence has suddenly
sparked in places you wouldn't expect it
I think that's why what happened here in
Leila Rose it shocked so many people
because it's it's just come out of a
clear blue sky and that has what is in a
sense I think been the motif of this
disorder it's been extremely intense and
that there's certainly been times when
I've said when you have thought how on
Earth will they get this uh under
control let's just go back to the
Catalyst for the sun rest Adam it's a
week ago it feels a lot longer that
naiel mezuk was shot and killed by
police 17 years old remind us about what
happened what we now know
yeah well it was a it was a Tuesday
Morning uh he was 17 he was too young to
drive but he was driving and he was
behind the wheel of a pretty high
powered yellow Mercedes car which was
stopped by the police now what happened
around that point is hotly disputed the
initial uh Claim by the police was that
uh was that now uh had tried to run them
down that was clearly disproved by video
footage that emerged which showed the
car out of halt because you can see two
police officers next to the car one of
them is pointing a gun in holding at a
quite a curious angle and then the car
moves forward and you hear the gun fire
that shot killed so what is Undisputed
is that that police officer shot
that that's a fact and he has been
placed under formal investigation for
voluntary homicide but bottom line is
that his shooting triggered outrage in
the community in Ontario well he's not
putting too fine a point in it so the
police are seen as the enemy they are
seen as being an intimidating presence
as soon as being racist uh as being
effectively a cancer within that
Community which is a deprived low-income
Community with low levels of literacy
high levels of crime and those tensions
simply boiled over into violence that
night in non-terre which in the
subsequent days spread through obviously
continuing through non-tare but into the
likes of Leon and Marseille and other
places through France now Niall's
grandmother has since said that some of
the people being violent and rioting are
using her son's name as a pretext for
destroying all this stuff explain the
more deeply rooted issues at play here
yeah I I don't think there's any doubt
that she's right early stage ages of
this were driven by anger but then when
you have several days later people in
distant cities looting shops and
stealing TVs I don't think that anybody
can pretend that that is an act of
protest because of the death of a
teenager of many hundreds of miles away
I think there are a few things to say
here at Sally's number one non-tear on
those first few nights of disorder was a
a pretty hairy dangerous place and one
of the reasons is that there are areas
of non-term that were simply a no-go
zone for the police they were too
dangerous for them to go into they were
controlled by gangs we saw them
ourselves who had Lookouts on Corners
with rocks and anybody going in was
getting pelted with rocks was getting
intimidated was getting threatened
people were being beaten up that's about
intimidation but on the second I think
it was obvious that that control of the
streets was intoxicating for some of the
people there that as the nights went on
they felt that they were almost
Untouchable that they were they were in
control and that they could do anything
they wanted and really not suffer
significant consequences and that
attitude I think spread around France
spread around some of these these big
city is that it was a period of impunity
it's a bit of a mess it's a social
economic cultural problem and successive
French administrations have talked about
addressing it and they haven't but in
the short term does it feel like the
police may have got the riots and
protests under control well I mean it's
one of those sort of classic that time
of writing moments I'm sitting in a cafe
here with the sun beating down to us
and there's just been a a pro well a
stand to remember to stand in support of
the mayor whose home was attacked and a
lot of people came they sang the
national anthem there was an air of
defiance and I think there was also a
tinge of optimism that we are on the
downslope the police have been flooding
the streets 45
000 officers out on the streets for the
last few nights I think the police
believe that they have broken the back
of it but they are absolutely not
complacent because this
you know we've seen a lot of fires over
the past few days and everyone here
knows that it only takes one spark to
get them to get them flaming again so I
I think that that complacency won't come
and so they know that it wouldn't take a
lot frankly for for this flame to be
revived
[Music]
France has an enormous race issue and
more importantly it has the numerous
races of issue Gene Beeman is an
associate professor of Sociology at the
University of California an author of
Citizen Outsider children of North
African immigrants in France so I've
been conducting research research on
Race racism and migration in France for
about 15 years and in light of all that
Gene have you been surprised by what
you've seen in France in the last week
unfortunately no I'm very saddened by
what's happening in France in the past
week but I'm not at all surprised and I
would argue that you know if you talk to
many black and brown individuals across
France they are not surprised either
because this unfortunately is just one
example the latest example of a long
history of police violence against
minoritized individuals so we can't
understand
um the sort of you know current
situation in the banyas without
understanding Francis Colonial history
and much of the Maghrib and parts of
West Africa
um to put it very simply closed
captioning not available
[Music]
there is a heightened police presidents
in many of these communities which only
exacerbates the distance between
residents and the police unfortunately
it's often a case in which the police
see these residents as enemies rather as
you know fellow French citizens or
fellow French residents that's a kind of
thinking that dates back to France's
Colonial history so essentially French
cities have these suburbs known as the
bondia where the French government began
to provide social housing on mass if you
like after World War II and they've
become increasingly occupied by
low-income families many migrant
communities essentially they've been
underfunded by successive governments
for years with poor quality housing job
prospects and very often they're labeled
problem or high risk areas in terms of
the clashes that they have with the
police
niel's grandmother has spoken out what
do you make of her comments in terms of
this not being about Niel it's it's
about something bigger definitely
empathize with her you know saying that
they're people who are sort of piling on
and not doing this in the interest of
her grandson but at the same time it's
not surprising that this is happening
because usually because you know this
usually it's just a spark that leads to
a broader sort of call or a broader
Revolt which is what you're seeing in
France it's started with just you know
the case of nails death but it really
reverberates to a broader phenomenon a
broader social problem up police
violence that France refuses to
acknowledge how much does the unrest
essentially represent self-harm in terms
of ruining infrastructure and public
services in areas that are already
deprived I would say it's a social
biologists we have to think about the
broader context of structural conditions
of some of these communities so when you
put people in communities that are more
deprived that are less advantaged in
other communities and uh you know deny
these communities with more amenities
more services it's hard for people to
feel a particular sort of investment in
these communities that are not seen as
really theirs you have to also think
about you know the everyday lives of
people living these communities that
again is fueling this kind of tension
this kind of action I take your point
about self-harm but I think we also have
to understand that these are often
individuals who try to make their
concerns heard and other means and other
in other modalities and have not been
heard and oftentimes you know uprisings
like this are a matter of last resort
nayel was a North African Heritage if
he'd been white do you think he'd have
been shot no I do not there always are
have been and you know presumably will
be cases of police violence against
white individuals or individuals
constructed as white or red as white but
we have to understand that those will be
disproportionately less than as much
research has shown violence or police
violence against North African or black
individuals and how much is racism an
issue among French police we could think
about France the French police as you
know systematic systemically racist as
an institution if we think about the
general origins of the police again
going back to the Colonial period and
the role of the police and enforcing
boundaries between colonizers and
Colonial subjects so that's one answer
but you know more sort of locally if you
will there have been lots of stories
that have demonstrated that many people
many current French police officers
identify or at least have voted for the
pronationale on the far-right party so
we see a sort of pervasiveness of this
kind of xenophobia xenophobic racist
kind of kind of culture within the
police department uh police department
institution of French police itself even
once the police have have a handle on on
these protests
how does France go about solving the
bigger problems here then more deeply
rooted social issues like in the
institution of police we have to create
the Fantastic create and accountability
mechanism
um for incidents like this for police
officers who commit this kind of
violence at present the French police
has a lot of leeway in terms of what
what is called they can totally not
detai or these identity control checks
in which they can stop individuals seen
as suspicious and sort of ask about
their asks about their whereabouts and
going through their belongings and this
sort of unchecked behavior only fuels
the tensions between French minorities
and the police that sometimes leads to
violence and and death such as the case
is this so we need to sort of set up a
different core fancy to set up a
different culture around what the police
are even allowed to do what they have
the
um legitimacy to do before there could
be any kind of repair and then secondly
it becomes very difficult in the context
of France to talk about police violence
outside of an active acknowledgment of
the existence of race and racism which
again due to France's Universalist
ideology they're very unwilling to do so
so without a sort of Reckoning with that
and a recording with Francis Colonial
history and the legacies and the
aftermath and present-front Society it's
very hard to imagine a way a positive
way forward frankly and do you think
there's the will in France to invest
more in these deprived communities and
try and improve the status quo I think
there's a
result particularly people in those
communities particularly people who've
been doing this kind of activism as
again as I said for decades I'm not yet
clear that there's a will among sort of
the uh French mainstream or French
politicians you know I think I wonder
um you know once things go back to
quote-unquote normal if anything will
actually change after this
my thanks to Gene Beeman and Adam
Parsons and to you for listening to the
Sky News Daily with me Sally Lockwood
this episode was produced by solar
aparicio with Alex Eden
[Music]